so at what point after a woman meets a
man does she owe him honestly her
thoughts and feelings about him
like i wouldn't say like oh oh my god i
had a guy ask me this on the first date
he's like so what do you think of me i'm
like
i feel like no one should be answering
those type of questions because like you
can't like from from the first date when
you meet you can't really
this is
you don't know them at all like you
don't owe them an explanation of what
like it's it's the same as asking like
what are we the first week that you've
been you've seen each other it's like
it's i think a better question to ask is
like is there a second date because then
you're not asking okay like what do you
want like you're showing interest like
do you want a second day like what that
my gosh where are you going
yeah i asked you to read that question
again
i was gonna hear it oh get the details
of it questions
yeah the question let me scroll up um at
what point after a woman meets a man
does she owe him honesty in her thoughts
and feelings about him
yeah did you okay i think um
because like every like
relationship or situation i guess kind
of rolls at different timings
and i would say like why would you want
to force someone to tell you how they
feel like shouldn't they be the one to
open up to you instead of like you know
tell me how do you feel about me like
wouldn't you rather have them like have
feelings for you and just be like
wanting to tell you you know i feel like
a lot of guys don't like listen to the
signs
where it's like
i don't think my time so
i think yes i think they just need like
you to full-on just be like i like you
yeah
i think
men don't actually like to read into
things i think women do
but like men choose not to so
or consciously just don't know how to
yeah i've interpreted that question in a
very different way okay i interpret it
as in like if you just met someone in
the first it would come back to the
first date scenario
like should you tell him immediately or
or at some point after the date mm-hmm
well i'm not feeling you
know doing this again rather than deep
feelings i think you guys went for a
emotional deep oh okay
as well just every day so like during
the day like okay let's say we're on a
date like during the day we're like i'm
gonna go now because i'm not feeling the
day like i feel like that would be like
really i'd rather no no you don't see
that you don't see that right there but
i think the question is more like well
after you had a date like when
somebody's like what when do you keep
talking and stringing it long or she
should it be honestly actually you know
that we're going to love meeting you but
i don't want to see you again i think
it's good courtesy to like um after the
date to write to them and tell them okay
i enjoyed the day or i didn't enjoy the
letter yeah like okay you get your you
can
get that
get your get your pigeons
don't touch your neck not even
first class my standard
five was
so just like send them a message and
like oh i enjoy the day i would like to
have a second day i enjoyed the date but
i don't think we'll have a second date
that's basically the bare minimum but
again my interpretation it might be
different one to the reception that's
what how soon after the first day the
next day
yeah next day
i don't know um no go ahead if i don't
like a guy i'd just text them right out
like afterwards
yeah just like get this done
i just let them know the next time they
ask me or if they even do ask me you
know
i just i don't know i'm
i'm very non-confrontational so i know
what you mean i feel like it's quite
difficult as a woman to kind of
i don't know
yeah to like break things off because
men will make it that might make it
easier they're like oh like i don't want
to see you again like why i'm like but
isn't this
i enough to get more feedback so you
said something three months ago so you
um don't you said something i'm going to
challenge it it's not that men don't
want to see signs and read signs we're
not as good at reading inside and seeing
signs yeah
it's not we know that we're not we don't
we don't want you so we're not as good
as it as you are so you might be putting
signals out but we just miss them i'm
sure yeah
it's been an example would have liked a
guy seen a guy liked him and you think
you did the most to get his attention he
ain't [ __ ] seeing it he's not he's
not yeah he's like oblivious to it
sometimes it's gotta be we we
have to be sometimes to be quite obvious
and quite belated with us because we're
not picking we don't get the subtlety
sometimes yeah but i do feel like
i mean like someone can
i mean i think like just men are they're
just naturally more like logical and
they don't do the
like what does this mean what does this
mean does this mean like we can do a lot
of things but pick up on like little
hints they don't yeah they don't do the
overthinking that we kind of do like we
think like oh everything like kind of
not everything but like you know you're
like you're looking at the details thing
you may really look at the details and
then kind of look at the general picture
what something means so for example
you've got a partner right maybe you've
been in a way of your partner and and
like walked to a room with like women
and you like seen them or got a vibe
from them that they're watching your
young man and you're like
she's a [ __ ]
that's the time but there's a
territorial coming up what are you
talking about
he's not seen anything he's not or he's
not seen the way you see she's flirting
with him and he's saying no we're just
talking his have a nice conversation and
you see more than you know is the
territorial thing funny that you say
because the other thing like it was like
switched around oh really yeah and i was
like oh like i'm just like talking to my
friends and they're like and he's like
friends i'm like
yeah like friends like they're not your
friends
if
if again if a guy and a girl are in a
relationship right can can the girl have
guy friends and can you can the boy has
women do you think like men can really
be friends with women at this point
i'm sorry i i had to just throw it out
and throw that out
otherwise but now like i just changed i
think okay i think most of the time no
but there are a few exceptions
family friends
i think like if you grew up together you
can have genuine friendships
i think but growing up together can lead
into that religion you know into the it
can yeah but but i think like there are
genuine friendships where you grew up
together i think there are genuine
friendships where like sometimes people
just live by each other and like they
just become friends that way yeah like
next when i become things yeah like or
they're in the same
like friend group i think those are the
three ways where genuine friends happen
like maybe like the sexuality or it's
not
you're not the preference so let's say i
don't want to say like the time like gay
best friend cause that's kind of weird
but like if someone's like not your
preference and you're best friends then
then then you know but you've put them
in a friend zone they usually still
might want you so the question still
exists can they still be friends because
he doesn't want to be a friend
i don't understand but then i think okay
if that was the case though i don't
think that so like we wouldn't know that
would be the case and then so then we
won't pick up on that we will push that
and so like would it be would it really
be our fault if like we're still we
considered like
yeah really
a moment ago we just agreed that women
have better pickup signals and they both
going to tell me that you can have a guy
for not know he's attracted to you but i
would say like expect first of all i
would say like when you kind of like
categorize that like person as like a
friend then you say that you don't see
any other signal i understand that you
criticize him as a friend but you still
know that he wants more than oh if i
knew
even even
you know you you've never had a
girlfriend that you know liked you
i feel like a lot of guy friends choose
like attractive friends or like they'll
only be friends with attractive women if
they're going to be friends with them so
that's why i'm really like because they
want you that's why i'm like
yes this is why i'm suspicious of
girlfriends like both ways like i'm
watching out because i i thought it was
innocent but now i see through the lines
i'm sorry it's never innocent it's never
in a sense it's never been interesting
relationship problems yeah
they're right there i mentioned this
like on one of the podcasts i've been on
before i was like it sucks sometimes
like being a woman like trying to be
friends with guys because you never know
when they secretly just want to [ __ ] you
all the time
but like in the end when that does
happen it just sucks because then like
you see all these things that you've
done with them and they're like okay i
actually didn't mean anything because
all you want to do is [ __ ] yeah and it's
kind of lousy because they went all this
way like they're playing the long game
playing the longest of games just to
[ __ ] you like which is so which is a bad
strategy guys that doesn't work
have you ever had a guy make it at the
friend zone short and sweet oh wait
actually i have
did he play the long game he did
what oh sorry no no that was me you
didn't end up with him so no i did not
that is bad how did he get out of the
friend zone how did he get out of the
front door
left right left right hand oh i didn't
last afternoon pearl don't release them
um
i
because i didn't reject him because i
wasn't attracted to him i thought he was
very attractive i rejected him because
he he was like
too much of a horror so
weakness from you
and so and like three and he'd been just
pursuing me for like years at that point
so i was like oh maybe he actually like
likes me you know what i mean because
it's been like three years okay that's a
long time
was it worth it was the whole reputation
was the whole this whole his whole
reputation did he live up to the
reputation of being a [ __ ]
nothing happened like that with like no
i mean it ended for um different reasons
but
but that wasn't why like it didn't work
out but
um
yeah i guess that like like but i
rejected him for a different reason it
wasn't because i wasn't attracted to him
okay that's not like your typical male
friend you know what about like men have
you had a female friend that you've
known as a friend and then you've
changed men don't put women in friend
zones
yes they no wait yes yes they yes yes
they do yes they do listen now listen
listen yes they do they just sleep with
them and then yeah
yes exactly yes yes yes
that's that's a good yeah yeah
we don't we don't put women into our
friends
sex with a friend now or like a friend
or a woman
so you've had sex with a woman and
you're no longer interested in having a
casual relationship with her but you're
on good terms yeah she's a favorite
she's a friend now isn't she yeah it's
different and she's also casual sex
no but you're no longer having casual
sex
for some reason and you're still you're
still amicable that's a female friend
yeah that that that that they're kind of
close that can happen
that can happen of a guy but the
difference is opposite of women so you
will put a fred guy in a friendzone
without [ __ ] him first
hmm
so what are the categories that you guys
put women in friends with benefits
of benefit like and then like possible
relationship and that's it and then
that's why whoa really
someone that you'd want to have kids
with and then like friends with benefits
and then let's say like wifey like what
is wifey category though what do you
mean how did you get from friends with
benefits to wifey
but i opened the door
so you've never met a girl that you know
you were not attracted to but you're
like oh this is a really cool girl i
want to be her friend like i want to
like you know play basketball with her
like play like you know whatever
or like you know drink some rum
[Music]
you might be attracted to them because
they may say things and do things yeah
difference what what difference is this
as a as men we're attracted to what we
see
right we match up to what they hear
so i could tell sweet last women and
they fall for you even though i tried
you might be trying to see him he said
the right words and he'll get you yeah
we don't that same thing doesn't work
with us we like what we see women's
fight or flaw
i do love me a good sweet talker
when we see a woman yeah we're seeing
her in pretty much two different ways we
will give when most men all men give
women attention right because
you like it actually without giving
attention right
but what would the thing that
i want to say all but i think when women
get confused they confuse
sexual attention
with romantic attention so that's
because you give attention doesn't mean
that we like you just want to [ __ ] you
but like just different to us want to
wife you yeah but how would we know
because let's say how look let's say
you've got tinder a guy will only swipe
on you if he's attracted to you and you
go to your first date like very quickly
how do you know this person's intent
without being pushy that's really
difficult to find out because if a guy
okay is only interested you sexually
first off the best how do you know
so i'm going to say something to you
then answers your question so i'm going
to say it first and say to us they think
it's stupid
they think we're stupid oh dating oh
dating isn't it so there's no purpose
it's it's it's redundant doesn't make
any sense your grandpa your grandparents
they got married quickly had long raised
ships dating doesn't work well then why
aren't you married